[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance he is now almost certainly
almost unavoidably the soon to be future
ex-president of the United States that
first draft of the James Comey firing
letter that story that got suitably
buried by the hurricane and daca and
North Korea that first draft should be
the end it may take two years to get
there or two hours but it is the end the
original draft of the Comey letter that
Trump and Stephen Miller reportedly
wrote four pages reportedly full of
anger over Russia and details of trumps
many meetings with Comey means that the
firing is no longer just likely
obstruction of justice
it is likely premeditated obstruction of
justice with a paper trail and Special
Counsel Robert Muller has a copy but
wait there's more it's actually worse
even than that it's essentially
premeditated obstruction of justice in
the White House in the Oval Office by
the President to stop an investigation
of the president's campaign and his
transition team and his administration
and ultimately himself and there was
apparently a warning to the president by
the White House Counsel not to do it
because the word reportedly used was
it's problematic the White House Counsel
mr. McGann seems to have warned the
president not to send the letter not to
fire the FBI director not to do it and
he reportedly also took a copy of the
letter and marked it up and gave it back
to Stephen Miller with quote several
sections that he believed needed to be
removed and for all we know he may as
well have used the phrase obstruction of
justice and then the president fired
Comey anyway and all of a sudden there
were different reasons for firing him
and all of a sudden there was this other
letter written by the Deputy Attorney
General which seems to have been rushed
into existence to cover up the real
reason he fired the FBI director anyway
and there's a paper trail and Robert
Muller has the original letter and there
are witnesses because Trump reportedly
read or described the letter in the
White House in the Oval Office on the
8th of May to the White House Counsel
Don Magan to the Vice President to the
senior adviser hope picks
- Jared Kushner under the fire chief of
staff Reince Priebus and they are all
screwed - unless that is the New York
Times The Washington Post and Rupert
Murdoch's Wall Street Journal are all
not merely wrong but have all fabricated
a story the same story Trump is guilty
of obstruction of justice and in writing
that letter Trump has in essence already
confessed to it he is now almost
certainly almost unavoidably these
soon-to-be future ex-president of the
United States the main problem for Trump
is that all these people who reportedly
saw or heard about that letter that day
the vice president and the White House
Council included among them could now be
subject to being questioned in front of
the grand jury
if White House Council McGann is asked
did you tell the president he had to
change that letter because firing call
me for those reasons would be a crime
and McGann says yes then Trump is in
desperate trouble as the long term
former federal prosecutor Renato
Marriott I put it on Twitter if Trump
did it anyway that would be slam dunk
evidence of a corrupt intent and McGann
can't refuse to testify and Trump cannot
keep him from testifying by claiming
executive privilege or attorney-client
privilege because nearly 20 years ago
another Special Counsel got a court to
rule that government attorneys can't
avoid grand jury questions about
government officials having potentially
committed criminal acts a special
counsel who got that established was Ken
Starr and the loser in that case was
Bill Clinton as the former prosecutor
Mariotti also noted if the White House
Counsel says I didn't tell him it was
illegal I didn't think it was illegal I
just didn't like the tone of the letter
Crump could actually be in the clear
here unless unless any of the other
people in the room contradict him when
they testify to the grand jury without
knowing how anybody else in the room
testified themselves to the grand jury
or unless they produced that marked up
copy of the letter McGann gave back to
Stephen Miller telling him he had to
take out these paragraphs and those
paragraphs and those paragraphs aren't
about tone
but they're about Russia in the worst
case scenario the president and his
senior advisor Miller started a plan to
illegally dismiss the FBI director and
they left a paper trail then the White
House Counsel learned of this plan tried
to stop it left his own paper trail and
may have to wind up testifying against
the president because then somebody
decided to start another conspiracy with
the Deputy Attorney General to come up
with an excuse letter with which to
dismiss the FBI director anyway so the
Acting Deputy Attorney General is in it
too and just for good measure they ran
it past OPEC Stephen Miller Jared
Kushner Rance brevis everybody else they
could find and all of them got
conspiracy stains all over them and of
course they also did that to the vice
president as a right-wing commentator
for The Washington Post
Jennifer Rubin noted attention will soon
focus on the vice president what did he
hear did he know the proffered reason
for the termination was phony and if so
did he knowingly mislead Congress and
the American people when he advanced the
cover story mr. pence who seems to have
skated away just before the ice cracked
under general Mike Flynn could for the
first time be in a world of hurt of his
own here he could easily be a grand jury
witness testifying against the
president's white House Counsel or the
president's son-in-law or the president
it is entirely plausible that Pence is
only way out of this mess that trump
created with the first draft of the
Comey letter could easily become turning
on Trump and that's if he had no idea
that the White House Counsel was
furiously trying to stuff the toothpaste
back into Trump's tube and oh by the way
another little detail that kind of got
lost in the more obvious more hateful
stories about Trump in the hurricane and
Trump in North Korea and Trump and daca
is that trumps security guy of nearly
two decades his permanent body man his
advisor his gatekeeper an ex New York
cop named Keith Schiller up and quit
over the weekend supposedly because he
missed the money and his old lifestyle
an old lifestyle which has involved
Trump and more money in his old life
which is involved Trump and more money
and Trump and more money every day since
1999 so I don't know how leaving Trump
gets him back to his old Trump lifestyle
but you know who delivered the letter to
commis office when Trump fired him right
the same guy Keith Schiller but it's
just a coincidence like it was a
coincidence that just before all this
broke Trump's lawyers went to Muller's
office and slimed Comey as an unreliable
witness and explained why Trump wasn't
guilty of obstruction of justice like it
was a coincidence that out of the blue
last Friday
Trump suddenly slammed Comey and talked
about a rigged system on twitter after
months of ignoring both topics like it
was a coincidence that the president
reportedly wrote a furious long letter
telling the FBI director who's firing
him for apparently not publicly clearing
him about Russia then coincidentally the
White House Counsel saw it and the next
thing you know there was a really short
coincidental firing letter and presto
there was also another coincidence a
letter from the Attorney General deputy
about how bad an FBI director the FBI
director was oh and the vice president
being in the middle of this also a
coincidence as the punchline to a joke
that's at least thirty years old goes
coincidence I think not two years or two
hours I don't know anymore
but he is the soon to be future
ex-president of the United States and I
wouldn't need long odds to bet against
Mike Pence as well resist remove peace
and look I don't know if my book is out
before he is out but it's called Trump
is effing crazy and it'll be available
by October 17th and you can pre-order it
now or don't and just wait for your
subpoena